JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you've been learning
about triple integration,
and I have a nice average
value problem for you
using triple integration here.
So what I'd like you to do is
to consider the tetrahedron that
has vertices at the origin,
and at the points (1, 0, 0)
and (0, 1, 0) and (0, 0, 1).
So that's one point on
each of the positive axes,
at distance 1 from the origin.
So I've taken the liberty
of drawing it here for you.
So consider that
solid tetrahedron.
And what I'd like you to do
is find the average distance
of the points in that
tetrahedron from the xy-plane.
All right.
So I'd like you to compute the
average value of the distance,
as the point ranges over
the whole tetrahedron,
of its distance
from the xy-plane.
So why don't you
pause the video,
spend some time working
that out, come back,
and we can work it out together.
Hopefully, you had some
luck with this problem.
Let's get started.
So the average value of a
function F over a region R
is going to be 1 over
the volume of the region
times the triple integral
over your whole region
R of the function value f of
x, y, z with respect to volume,
in any order you want.
So I guess I'll write dV here,
and then to evaluate this,
you set it up as an
iterated integral.
So in our case,
the function we're
trying to find the
average value of
is the distance between
a point and the xy-plane.
But that's an easy
function, right?
That's just z.
For any point in space, its
distance from the xy-plane
is just its height.
It's z-value.
So the function
that we're seeking
to find the average
value of is z,
and so most of the
work of this problem
then is going to be in figuring
out what the bounds are
and then doing the actual
integral after that.
So OK.
So let's think about the bounds.
This tetrahedron is a
nice, reasonably simple,
geometric object.
So in fact, it doesn't
matter too much which order
you take your bounds.
So I think I'm going to do
it in the order dz dy dx.
You know, I'll do z first,
and then y, and then x.
But it doesn't matter.
If you do it a
different way, it'll
probably work out very
similarly overall,
and you'll still be able to
compare the overall process.
So let's think about z.
Yeah?
So in this tetrahedron, we
want to integrate with respect
to z first.
So we look at this
tetrahedron and we say, OK,
at a point x and
y-- you know, when
we choose the x-
and y-values, what's
the lowest surface-- what's
the smallest value z can take--
and what's the upper
surface-- what's
the largest value z can take?
So the lowest surface
here is the xy-plane.
That's the bottom face
of this tetrahedron.
And for any choice of x
and y, the lowest value z
can take is when
it's in the xy-plane.
So when it's equal to 0.
So this is going to be
equal, so in our case,
so let's set this up.
So it's going to be
an iterated integral.
The function we're
integrating is z,
and I said we'll do dz dy dx.
And we just said that the lowest
value that z takes-- the dz--
is 0.
So the highest
value that z takes
is when it hits
this top surface.
This plane that passes through
the point (1, 0, 0), (0, 1, 0),
and (0, 0, 1).
All right.
So we need to know the
equation of that plane.
Luckily, that's a
pretty easy plane
to write down the equation for.
So this slanted plane passing
through the three vertices
other than the origin is the
plane x plus y plus z equals 1.
All right.
So it's a nice, easy
plane to work with.
And so what we want
to know is what's
the value of z on that plane.
So we isolate z on one side and
we bring everything else over.
So we have that top value
of z, the largest value of z
that z can take when x and y
are fixed, is 1 minus x minus 1.
So that's what goes up here.
So that's the biggest
value z can take.
OK, good.
So now we need to figure
out what the bounds on y
are in terms of x.
So what I like to
do in this case
is I like to draw a
projection of your surface.
So then you're in a
two-dimensional world,
and then you can look at
that image more easily.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to look at
this tetrahedron
and we're going to
imagine projecting it down
into the xy-plane.
So for every point
in the tetrahedron,
we're going to draw a dot
below it in the xy-plane.
And then we're going to
look at that set of dots.
So what that's going to
give us is this bottom face
of the tetrahedron.
Every point of the tetrahedron
is above its bottom face.
That's not true for
every tetrahedron,
but it's true for this one.
So the region that
we're interested in
is that bottom face.
So I'm going to draw another
picture of it over on my left
here.
So that region is the region
that has vertices (0, 0),
and (1, 0), and (0, 1).
So it's this triangle.
And this bottom
edge of the triangle
is the line y equals 0.
This left edge is
the line x equals 0.
And this slanted line is
the line x plus y equals 1.
OK, so this is that same
bottom face that we just drew.
But now I've changed my axes
to our usual two-dimensional
direction with x to
the right and y up.
OK.
So we're doing dy next.
So we need to figure
out for a fixed value
of x, what are the bounds on y?
So we see from this picture
that for any fixed value of x, y
goes from 0-- the
x-axis-- up to this line.
OK?
So on the x-axis, y takes the
value 0, and on this line,
y takes the value 1 minus x.
Finally, our outermost
variable of integration
is x, and so we
need to know what
are the absolute largest and
smallest values that x takes.
So we can do that looking
either at this picture
or looking at our
original picture.
Either way, it's not
hard to see that x just
goes between 0 and 1.
The smallest value that x
takes in this tetrahedron is 0.
The largest value it takes is 1.
So that's our integral
that we have to compute.
So that's not that bad at all.
So now you have to go
through and you have
to actually integrate this.
Yeah?
And so I'm going to look at
my notes just to make sure
I don't make any big
arithmetic mistakes.
So let's see.
Now we do these one at a time.
So this innermost integral
is an integral of z dz.
OK, well that's easy.
That's z squared over 2.
And then we're taking z
squared over 2 between 0 and 1
minus x minus y.
So this innermost integral is z
squared over 2 between 0 and 1
minus x minus y.
So that's equal to-- so the
innermost integral gives us 1
minus x minus y squared over 2.
So that's what we get for
the innermost integral.
So our integral that
we're looking at, then,
is equal to the
integral, as x goes
from 0 to 1, of the integral
as y goes from 0 to 1 minus x
of this integrand.
So this is the inner one.
Let me write that, "inner."
That's what I've got here.
Just integrating z with respect
to z gives me z squared over 2.
And then I evaluated at
the bounds of the integral.
OK, so now I need to
do the middle one.
So let's do that up here.
So I need to compute
the integral.
So now I take the bounds,
so the middle one is y,
and the bounds are from 0 to 1
minus x, of the inner integral.
This thing that I just computed.
So that's of 1 minus x
minus y squared over 2, dy.
OK.
So All right.
So this isn't that bad.
This is a quadratic
polynomial in y.
And so it's not
terribly hard to see.
I'm running a little
bit out of board space.
So I'm not going to give you
a full, detailed explanation.
But it's not hard
to see, I think,
that this integral of 1
minus x minus y squared
over 2 with respect to y is 1
minus x minus y cubed over 3,
but it's negative, because
the sign here is negative.
And you could check by
differentiating this and seeing
that you get that.
And so we have to evaluate that
as y goes from 0 to 1 minus x.
So what do we get?
Well, when y is equal
to 1 minus x, this is 0.
So we get 0 minus-- and when y
is equal to 0, this is minus 1
minus x quantity cubed over
6-- so it's minus minus 1
minus x cubed over 6, so that's
just 1 minus x cubed over 6.
And so finally, the
outermost integral
is we take the
inner two integrals
and we integrate
them with respect
to x as x goes from 0 to 1.
So it's the integral from 0 to
1 of 1 minus x cubed over 6, dx.
And that's going to equal-- I've
run out of space-- 1 over 24.
All right.
Except I've done something
wrong right at the beginning.
I hope you all caught me.
Right?
I had this 1 over V factor
here, and it disappeared.
Right?
I forgot about this 1
over V, so over here,
I should have written
1 over V right
in front of that integral.
I've correctly
computed 1 over 24
as the value of my
triple integral,
but the average height
here isn't 1 over 24.
It's 1 over 24V.
All right.
So the average height is 1
over 24V, and so we need to go
and we need to look
at our tetrahedron
and figure out
what its volume is.
So if we come over here
and see our tetrahedron.
Now this is nice,
simple tetrahedron.
The volume of a
tetrahedron is 1/3
the area of the base
times the height, right?
So this is a nice,
easy tetrahedron.
Its height is 1.
Its base is a right triangle
whose legs are both 1.
So the base area is 1/2,
so the volume is 1/6.
So if the volume
is 1/6, and we said
the average value is 1 over 24V,
so that works out to 1 over 4.
So let me write that
just in this space.
So the average height
then is 1 over 4.
So that's going to
be our final answer.
OK, so let's just recap
briefly what we did.
We had an average value
problem that we started with.
So we use this general formula
for average value problems.
When you have a
function f that you
want to take its average
value of over a region R,
what do you do?
Well, you take 1 over
the volume of the region
times the triple integral of
your function f with respect
to volume over that region.
OK.
So this is the average
value in general.
In our particular case, the
function was the height.
It was z.
And then you have to set it
out choosing the proper bounds
for your integrals.
So in this case, you choose
some order of integration
based on the region.
In this particular case,
it's a nice, simple region.
It doesn't matter too much
what order you choose.
So I chose dz dy dx.
And then what does that mean?
So for the innermost one, you
look at your original solid.
So I'm going to go back and
look at this picture again.
So for your innermost variable
you say-- so if it's z,
you say, so when I fix x and
y, what's the bottom surface
and what's the top surface
when I solve that for z
in terms of x and y?
So here, that was
the plane z equals 0,
and the plane z equals
1 minus x minus y.
So that explains my
bounds over here.
Why they were 0 and
1 minus x minus y.
Then, when you go to your
next variable-- in this case,
it was y-- what do you do?
Well, first you project to
eliminate this first variable.
So you project your region down.
Down in this case,
because it's z.
So you project in
the z-direction.
And you draw this
shadow of your region.
So this is what I drew here.
This is the shadow of my
region in the xy-plane,
after I projected it.
And then you do the same thing.
So now this just
like what you did
when you had to find bounds
for double integrals, when
you wrote them as iterated
integrals a few lectures ago.
And so then you
do the same thing.
So then, in this
case, I was next
integrating with respect to y.
So I needed to find the
bounds on y with respect to x.
So I needed to look,
in this picture,
at the bottom edge and the
top edge of this region.
And then your
outermost variable,
you look at its absolute bounds.
So the largest and smallest
value it takes on the region.
OK, then you have
an iterated integral
and you evaluate it by
successive integrations.
OK.
So that was what we did.
We just did the three integrals,
starting from the inside
and working our way out.